you read the title of this video you
know you clicked on I don't do explain
to you I'm sorry I've been watching a
lot of drew months
I drew oh the battery is dying mother
King we're back okay let's do this
these are my favourites for August let's
say that I put everything in this box
putting everything in a box is a special
skill set of mine first
yeah you see he said kiss yeah these are
Biore Pore strips er a they're the
Beyonce of power strips you probably
know what these are people have been
using them forever and I just didn't
until now and I love them they make me
look like I just got plastic surgery
done which is fun because I love
watching The Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills and better cosplaying them the
thing I didn't do the first time that no
one told me to do except the directions
definitely told me I just didn't read
them you got to wet your face and then
put the strip on top very sexual in the
overtones of that it's really fun it's a
great way to see firsthand just how
disgusting you are yeah
strong Keitha do you say I can't see how
clear cells rapid action pads because if
there's one thing I hate in a pad it is
slow action one I just worked as Clara
so in a couple videos for you where you
can see them right there and I actually
own this before I even started working
with Clara so and forgot I had it and I
pulled it out and started using them and
loved them
these are exfoliation pads you wipe them
over your face and they wipe dirt out of
your face I got a tip from when DJ Diaz
that after you use the Biore Pore strips
it's good to wipe your face with a toner
something like this so that your pores
will close back up because otherwise
these leave them open and ready for
business dirty dirty dirty business I
use them before I go to bed I use them
on them wake up in the morning they're
like Bagel Bites and it's not good for
your skin to wipe a bagel bite on your
face so
not the hard way this is a better
alternative yeah yeah yes yeah yes yeah
yes yeah this is Tarte Amazonian clay
waterproof brow mousse this is a mousse
for your brows and I really like it a
lot it comes with a little brush like
this as an angled brush and and then a
little spooley so you go and then this
is this gel mousse look you can look at
it and you dip the angle brush in and
then you draw in your brows and I love
it also a lot of times if you use a brow
pencil you might use a gel to keep the
hairs in place this kind of does both at
the same time and it doesn't look like
you get a ton in here but I've been
using this for a couple weeks and I have
hardly made a dent brows on fleek eek
eek eek knacks Matt he's saying I can't
say I said this is neither masonry dildo
but it is sky why is everything so
sexual this is Too Faced mascara and
it's called better than sex
that is the lofty claim I don't know
that I am officially behind that but I
do think it's hilarious how overly
sexual makeup names can be it doesn't
people at your face just spent all day
they're like God nurse got orgasm and a
bunch of other names what can we do guys
figure close call no that doesn't work
it's mascara and it's great I love it
like sex this mascara is it this mascara
is wet and sloppy it's good mascara you
know I like it so next yeah you Sam yeah
okay yeah this is a scent by philosophy
called compassionate
it's a creamy vanilla flavor but it's
not overly creamy what thank God it's
not overly creamy it's a creamy vanilla
flavor scent it doesn't smell too
vanilla II where you smell like a 14
year old trying to be an 18 year old and
it doesn't smell too much like soap
which so many fragrances smell like to
me they smell just like so it smells
like
but it's more like a musky vanilla like
a man like a like a man's vanilla you
know we always want to coat ourselves in
a man's vanilla right next yeah you say
yes say yes yeah this is a backpack from
the website
ASOS a sauce for like three days
straight I was looking for a leather
backpack online I decided that I wanted
to try and look more put together when I
traveled and I thought a leather
backpack would do that job for me and I
love this backpack
it's the navy blue color I think it was
like 40 bucks and it has a pocket for my
laptop which is really what I wanted
indeed I have a magazine that I haven't
read yet and two books that I also
haven't read yet that I should be
reading and some deodorant and lipgloss
and a phone charger so it appears that I
have set my backpack up as a lie whoever
owns this backpack and what's inside
really has an interesting organized
efficient life and really no look at
this
I spent time to set this up today max
yeah you see I can't see I can't you see
it this is a cardboard cutout of Hannah
Hart's twin I don't know why she got
this she got it from some shoot but she
tried to prank me by putting it in front
of my house but I caught her doing it
but now I am in possession of this thing
and when she comes over she likes to
hide it in different areas she had put
it in my shower the other day and I
didn't know and it was an awful awful
experience however I learned to love
this thing because I'm super paranoid
that I'm always gonna be kidnapped and
the great thing about this although it
frightens me it frightens other people
too I put it in front of my windows at
nighttime to give the illusion that I'm
never sleeping I'm always watching so
potential kidnappers I'm I'm awake and
reading cute well there you go they're
all my favorites for the month of August
I hope that this changed your life I
don't know
Brow's on Fleet what do they call it
when what do they call it when you're
really good at what do you call really
great what do you call what do you call
what do you call it when Google does
something cool brows are on fleek bye
goodbye I get it yeah God just go just
go just go just go leave next